le visage un peu plus fermé que lundi
olivier ferrand en déplacement au sens
de l' agence régionale de santé en ile
de france
pas de bonne nouvelle cette fois
annoncer aux français ils n'avaient pas
l'info babouche ce sont des gens qui
sont positifs et quite a confirmé aux
variants oui maintenant oui pour
certains oui à l'auto de paris
les variants venue du mozambique
d'angleterre ou encore d'afrique du sud
inquiète le gouvernement
le ministre de la santé venus pour
s'informer mais aussi faire taire toute
polémique lié au vaccin
nous n'avons pas à ce stade les 6
millions d'accès nous sommes donc dans
un fonctionnement à flux tendu à chaque
fois que des vaccins nous sont livrés
toutes les semaines
immédiatement ils sont répartis dans les
neuf centres de vaccination dans
l'ensemble du territoire national et
donc à mesure que ces vaccins arrivent
nous ouvrons des créneaux de vaccination
[Musique]
terminé
plus de deux millions de français âgés
de 75 ans et plus ont pris rendez vous
selon les derniers chiffres du ministère
quatre autres millions de candidats sont
aussi éligibles
un chiffre important et sujet de
préoccupation pour les élus locaux
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas exactement le
nombre de vaccins qu'on aura et ça ce
n'est pas normal parce qu'il y a de plus
en plus de personnes qui ont le kovy 19
est de plus en plus de personnes qui
veulent se faire vacciner
il faut que ça suive l'état ne doit de
la transparence
les stocks sont gérés au compte gouttes
les programmations sont gérés trop
lentement
nous ne savons pas quand nous recevrons
plus de doses nous n'avons aucune
visibilité
les doses qui arrivent sont de 5 mille
doses par semaine et la seine saint
denis compte plus de 1 million de
personnes il semble qu'il y ait un
problème d'approvisionnement
le gouvernement ne répond pas aux
attentes de nos concitoyens
le gouvernement rassure qu aucun stock
n'est caché à l'échelle nationale et
prône l'équité et la transparence avec
l'annoncé en fin de semaine du nombre
précis de de ce que possèdent les 900
centres de vaccination du pays
nous sommes évidemment et vous le savez
comme les autres pays dépendant du
nombre de doses qui nous sont livrés
bien entendu il faut dire la vérité
la vaccination c'est une opération de
masse qui concerne le monde entier
les capacités de production sont à bloc
et la france profitera au même rythme
que les autres
le ministre informe que tout français
ayant essayé de prendre rendez-vous son
succès se verra rappelé en priorité par
les centres de vaccination une procédure
qui doit être également initié avant la
fin de semaine mais sans encore de date
précise